&gt;&gt; For the third practice problem, we were wondering how many tickets were sold.
How many adult tickets and how many kid tickets. So, these must be the
variables. We can let a equal the number of adult tickets, and we can let k
equal the number of kid tickets. It doesn't matter what variables you use. You
could use a smiley face or even a diamond. It just matters that you use the same
variable for the number you're representing throughout the problem. These are
the two equations we need to set up. The number of adult tickets and the number
of kid tickets should equal our total number of tickets. Using our variables, I
have a plus k is equal to 500. 500 was the total number of tickets sold for the
fundraiser. The second equation involves the amount of money earned from adult
tickets and the amount of money earned from kid tickets. If we add those two
amounts together, we should get the total amount of money, which was $3312.50.
I've written our two equations down here and this time, I'm going to solve it
using elimination. We don't always have to use substitution. I'm going to
multiply this equation through by a negative 4 so I can end up eliminating the
ks. Here are the twp equations, and I can solve this equation for k. This allows
me to do substitution that can plug in 500 minus a in for k. Now, we don't
always need to do substitution, I could have multiplied this first equation by a
negative 4 and that would have let me eliminate the ks. I could of solved it
using elimination instead. Either way you do it, you should wind up with the
same answer in the end. First, I distribute the positive 4 to the 500 and the
negative a. Then, I combine like terms and subtract 2000. Our last step is to
divide by the coefficient of a, 3 and a half. And we get a is equal to 375. This
was the number of adult tickets that were sold for the fundraiser. We know the
total number of tickets must add up to 500. So, I can replace a with 375 to find
the number of kid tickets. Using some mental math here or an equation, we can
get k is equal to 125. This is the number of kid tickets we sold. And to be sure
that your answers are right, plug them in into your second equation to make sure
that the amounts add up to $3,312.50.